welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation
second harmonic generation detection of
res conformational changes and discovery
of a novel small molecule binder
presented by dr. frank mccormick
professor of the UCSF Helen Diller
family Comprehensive Cancer Center
my name is Xavier Guterres and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labrys laberd's
is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. McCormick I
will now turn the presentation over to
him thank you I'd like to describe our
work to try and identify small molecules
that bind to the chaos protein using a
new biophysical technique called second
harmonic generation the work that I'll
be describing was done mostly by a
postdoctoral fellow in my lab called
Elizabeth Donna and Donahue Vogue
[Music]
this summarizes the problem that we're
trying to address wrasse mutations occur
in a very large number of human cancers
but it play a primary driving role in
the development and progression of the
disease Rance potations occur most
frequently in pancreas cancer where
almost all pancreas cancers are caused
by activation of the k-ras on the gene
protein Harris potations also occur in
almost half of all colorful cancers and
a third of all lung cancers there are
three types of Rass protein in the cell
was dr human cancer chaos is the most
prominent shown in red on this slide but
n wrasse a cousin of chaos also plays an
important role in leukemias and in
melanoma and H Rast a role in bladder
cancer and thyroid cancer altogether
these wrasse oncogenes play a direct
causal role in over a million cancer
deaths per year and yet we have no drugs
that target the wrasse protein directly
and most of the drugs that we use to
treat cancers are not effective on
cancers in which chaos is mutated or
unrest or a stress for that matter so
this is a huge unmet clinical need and
we are determined to find molecules that
bind to chaos and block its function by
direct interaction the wrasse protein
has been described as the beating heart
of signal transduction partly because
because the protein is hard shaped and
also because during its normal function
it moves back and forth between two
configurations and on state and an off
state just like a beating heart and all
growth factors that that signals from
into cells signal through the wrasse
protein and activate the wrasse protein
to send signals downstream so this is an
essential part of all signal
transduction and the way that all cells
respond to external signals all these
signals channel through the wrasse
protein in cancer cells though with
wrasse potations the beating heart is
locked into the active state and signals
downstream persistently telling cells to
proliferate even though they have no
external signal and this is one of the
primary reasons that they
cause cancer the problem is really how
to fix the broken beating heart of
signal transduction either by preventing
it from signaling or eliminating the
whole protein altogether it's been
recognized for many years that this
protein does not have an active site to
its small molecules can easily bind
unlike kinase which have been
successfully exploited for cancer
therapy so this protein has been deemed
undruggable in the sense that medicinal
chemists did not see an opportunity to
interfere with this proteins function by
simply looking for - in T binding sites
that could be blocked with a small
molecule drug therefore most efforts to
target Rast
have focused on pathways downstream of
the rass protein that regulates this is
a complicated slide which we don't need
to go through in any detail except to
make the point that wrasse proteins are
part of a very complicated signaling
transduction network they're right in
the middle of this diagram so attempts
to block this network by finding small
molecules that binds a part argost
downstream of wrath' such as ran for mac
or oak pi4 kinase have not been
successful mostly because of the
complexity of the network and because we
now know when you block individual
proteins in this network then the whole
network readjusts and then the cells can
continue to proliferate as normal so
this is a dynamic flexible networks been
very difficult to shut down by targeting
individual proteins in the network so
this approach so far has not been
successful for treating cells in which
the network is perturbed by activated
rats so that is one problem we have in
rats drives a very complicated and
dynamic Network the second problem is
that in if we look at the network
between different cell lines derived
from different tumors we see very
different dependences on downstream
elements of this network so here's
another complicated diagram just to make
a very simple point but if we look at a
hundred different cell lines which is on
on the x-axis and analyze the dependence
of each of these cell lines
on different elements of a network that
I showed previously on the y-axis you
can see if you look at green squeak
green squares means that particular cell
line was dependent on that particular
downstream element of the network red
means the cells don't care and you can
see across the whole panel of the
hundred cell lines a very heterogeneous
response some cells care about
particular network components others
don't and with very few simple patterns
that emerge by looking at the whole
panel of cell lines so there's
tremendous heterogeneity in the
dependence of different elements of a
network as well as the plasticity of the
network itself so this makes things very
complicated if we just drill down on
dependence on a few well-known elements
of this complicated network such as the
RAF kinase which is shown on this slide
here on the third panel on the left side
bottom left here we show the dependence
of different cell lines in which blue
are pancreatic cell lines green are lung
and red are GI to minute rice our lines
and the further down that slope in each
case the more dependence the cell line
is on a particular protein and you can
see just just looking at these these
simple plots if you look at the raster
plot which again is on the Left panel
third from the top every sub
dependencies are all over the place some
star lines depend on RAF others don't
and it very very dramatically between
lung pancreas and GI tumors again
showing that very heterogeneous
dependence of downstream elements of the
network and therefore the complexity of
trying to shut down the whole network
with simple molecule drugs so going
downstream has not been an effective
strategy for these different reasons
therefore we'd like to target the wrasse
protein directly and stop the problem at
its source
the rats protein is a very beautiful
heart shaped protein that I showed in
the previous slide but it has another
important component and that is that
it's localized in the plasma membrane
through a tail at the c-terminal region
of the protein where the protein is
pronated and the farnesyl group
rocks grass protein into the plasma
membrane so this is a molecular dynamics
simulation of a rass protein in the
plasma membrane the light blue color is
the wrasse protein again snuggled up to
the plasma membrane which is the sort of
cloud at the top of the slide and here
we show its interaction with components
of a downstream Network the Arats
binding domain of RAF kinase which is in
yellow and the cysteine-rich domain of
RAF kinase which is in purple and here
you can see that rat protein with his
partner RAF snuggles up to the membrane
in a very close and intimate way and we
think that's a very important part of
the signaling of the wrasse protein so
some of the first attempts to target
Rast way back in the 1980s some of the
first attempts actually to target any
aquagenic protein focused on trying to
prevent raf proteins localizing to the
plasma membrane and this was attempted
by blocking the process of formation of
the wrasse protein so this cartoon shows
three rats proteins h n and k all
localized in the plasma membrane through
a c-terminal tail which is the black
black squiggle and that is the farnesyl
group which is the lipid tail which
locks whereas proteins into the plasma
membrane so it's recognized in the 80s
that the addition of this tail to the
rats proteins is mediated by an enzyme
called farnesyl transferase and in
efforts were made to inhibit farnesyl
transferase with drugs to block grass
function and indeed many very potent in
inhibitors of funds of transferase were
developed to block grass signaling by
preventing membrane localization
unfortunately for reasons which we
didn't understand at a time it turns out
that the two protein is the two raf
proteins that played a major role in
human cancer k rats and NRA's can be
modified by a backup system called
journal journal journal transferase
which is shown in red so when you block
constellation of grass proteins general
general de france' transferase takes
over and then the raft proteins can go
back to doing the thing call
in cancer interestingly hrs does not use
this backup system so a trance driven
tumors are actually sensitive to
farnesyltransferase inhibitors and
indeed a company called pura is now
testing whether or not
farnesyltransferase inhibitors may be
effective in tumor cells which are
driven by hrs mutations and that
represents 5% of bladder cancer about 5%
of thyroid cancer and about 5 to 10% of
squamous cell carcinoma of the head and
neck so in these part in these clinical
trials patients are selected the
patients for their mutations in hrs and
if they have such a mutation they are
then treated with funds for transferase
inhibitor to see if they we now block
the hrs function and have therapeutic
benefit and these studies are now in the
phase 3 clinical study for hopefully
proof of effectiveness but this drug
only works on hrs because N and K rats
have this backup system as we did we now
appreciate so another approach to
blocking K wrasse protesting I would be
to block for installation or general
generation of the chaos protein by
preventing both these enzymes attacking
the site on the chaos protein where
these modifications take place and that
site is sustained 185 on K rats so one
of the projects which we are working on
the Frederick National Lab is to develop
drugs which bind to the chaos protein
directly and prevents translation or
general generation by actually
covalently blocking the cysteine on the
Rass protein will be the acceptor of
these two modifications and the approach
that we're using is called tethering one
of several approaches to targeting chaos
directly so this approach uses the
library of small molecules that have
sustained reactive warheads and then we
react these is the little fragments with
the protein target and if they bind to
the protein closest by the cysteine they
form a covalent bond and then this will
block this is thing that's under attack
shown in the cartoon here so this we
have done and found several classes of
warheads and compound that covalently
react with the sustain and prevent phone
installation or general generation of
the chaos protein and this just shows
that in a cell line that has wild side
chaos on the Left panel exposure to
these compounds decreases the chaos
protein in the membrane by preventing
final installation or general generation
on the right panel we have no effect on
cells which which are driven by a mutant
form of chaos that doesn't depend on for
installation for its membrane
localization
and I want to acknowledge the work of
Anna Massey art at the Frederick
National Lab for her work in developing
these compounds so this simply shows
another approach to targeting chaos in
this case by preventing processing of
chaos that directly ideally we'd like to
find compounds that react with the
mutant form of chaos and not the
wild-type to give us the best
specificity for effectiveness without
effects on normal tissue this seemed
impossible many years ago but recently
my colleague have UCSF cave on show cat
developed an idea that there's now
developed into clinical compounds in
which chemicals are developed that
interact covalently with the g12c
mutation that is frequently mutated in
human lung cancer so normally there's a
glycine occurred on 12 but a mutation
occurs in that residue to convert it to
a cysteine residue which then lost the
rats protein into the into the active
state and causes cancer but the cysteine
residue itself can be attacked by
covalent modifications using the
tethering chemistry that I just
described in the previous slides the 212
C mutations therefore are vulnerable to
chemical attack and they occur
frequently in non-small-cell lung cancer
as shown in the pie chart on the bottom
right but the red sector is the fraction
of non-small cell lung cancers in which
g12c
is the major driver of the tumor do 12c
mutations
frequent in this form of lung cancer
because they are the hallmarks of
exposure to cigarette smoke you will see
in pancreatic cancer and in colorectal
cancer that the red sector is no smaller
showing that g12c mutations are much
less frequent in these cancers in in
these cancers g12 d Bartek mutation
occur on 12 is the most frequent
mutation that causes these cancers and
this would be another target for attack
if we can think of a way of developing
chemicals that attacks such a residue
that so far we have not now in terms of
compounds that bind directly to grass
proteins and inhibit them
one such compound is a compound that I
just described in the taxa sustain the
compound
ARS one six to zero and this shows where
that compound binds on the grass protein
also showing in the top box another
compound that binds to wrasse that was
discovered by another technique called
NMR based fragment screening this
approach was developed by Steve Fezzik
and colleagues at some other spy labs
and has been utilized by his group now
at Vanderbilt and also by a group of
Genentech to find small molecules that
bind to rats and other targets and the
approach here is to take a soluble form
of rass expose it to a small fragment
such as the one in a little box and if
the prey the compound binds to the rats
protein you see a shift on the NMR
spectrum and this tells you that you
have a binding compound and this
compound that I've highlighted here was
identified using that particular
approach so NMR based fragment design is
another approach to finding small
molecules that bind to rats and other
approaches have yielded compounds that
also bind Taurus so this is another
compound this is from the group of tario
rabbits in the UK that identified a
compound that displaces the raf binding
region of grass from from rats itself by
competing at the binding site so these
are small molecule fragments to bind to
shallow pockets on the rice protein then
they bind with rather lower affinity
again stressing that whereas proteins
don't have deep pockets to which
molecules combine so these are examples
of those molecules that could further be
developed to make them more more potent
but in the current state our low
affinity weak interactors at these sites
the group of Frederick National Lab has
solved a number of crystal structures of
chaotic proteins in the hope that they
will reveal new structures that have
pockets to a small molecules for buying
at high affinity and such structures are
shown these six examples are six mutant
proteins rats proteins that occur in
human cancers at high frequency from
left to right top to bottom and g12c eg
12 TG 12 V - 13 D Q 61 l + QC t1 are now
in these diagrams the blue segments at
the top of the structures of the part of
the protein call switch one switch one
is where RAF kinase binds to rats so any
compound that just the disrupted or
change the structure at switch one is
the likely to affect RAF binding now the
crystal structures of these proteins
show that three of these proteins that
is g12c on the top line - 12 t below it
and q61 l in the middle bottom line you
can see that the blue region at the top
of the protein is actually in a
different state and the wild-type
protein on the left or the other mutants
- 12 deg 12 v q61 are so for these three
particular mutant proteins the switch 1
region is in a state that is actually
open presenting a new pocket such a
small molecule could potentially bind
and hold the protein in the active
switch one-out configuration which would
be incapable of finding two rats two
rats I'm sorry so based on these
structures we believe that we have a
potential new approach to finding
molecules that could disrupt these
particular mutants selectively by
binding in these pockets
these are different approaches that that
have been used successfully NMR based
fragment design and covalent tethering
to find molecules that bind to rafts and
really make up for the fact that there
aren't deep pockets to which a molecule
combined and therefore we have to use
our the covalent approaches or NMR based
approaches to find compounds that
interact edimar based fragment design is
effective but requires very high
concentrations of protein and very
expensive and difficult and difficult
technology to actually conduct high
throughput screens with this as the
primary readout so a new technology has
been developed so recently by Josh
Thomas he and his colleagues then that
start by Odyssey which utilizes a
different biophysical feature of
proteins that enables one to identify
molecules to bind to the protein in a
high-throughput screening format with a
very small amount of protein and with
very high standard Tibetan so the check
the optical phenomenon is called second
harmonic generation and the way that it
works is that an incident light coming
in to a membrane that's shown on the
Left panel here and reflected again
using no typical TIRF microscopy
principles emits a secondary wave in the
z-axis are shown by that black arrow now
if we put a protein onto this membrane
and the protein that has a dye attached
to the protein that is a particular
chemical nature a resonance will occur
that sends a signal called second
harmonic signal typically to red photons
combined to give any blue photon as part
of the the second harmonic signal and
this resonance occurs between the
emitted sync though the blue photon and
the dye on the protein I run a small
molecule binds to the protein as shown
in the middle panel a green blob here
binds to the little pocket on the
protein the protein changes in
configuration and this changes the the
resonance between the the photons that
are impinging on the protein and the
second harmonic
wave and the important point here is a
very small change in the angle or the
protein on the membrane gives a very
significant change in the second
harmonic signal so a one degree change
in the orientation of the protein
relative to the membrane is a very
powerful signal which can be easily
detected using the detectors of the
second harmonic wave so this allows us
to see very small changes in protein
configuration such as those typical of
allosteric binding events to a protein
and enables us to screen for compounds
that bind to a protein using this as a
simple readout using rather standard
techniques the protein can be
immobilized on the membrane using a toe
tag on the protein such as the histidine
tag I was for bind to nickel in the
bilayer or protein can have can utilize
only tethering mechanisms such as the
farnesyl group in the case of rass to
bind to a a synthetic bilayer to stick
it into the membrane and once the
protein is in that configuration then
small changes in its in its orientation
relative to the membrane can be detected
by second harmonic generation now to
make the protein shg active one has to
conjugate the protein with a particular
tie to create a sh t really reactive
Morrisey on the protein and with Rass
we've done that by reacting a chemical
dye with with lysines on on the protein
they can also be done by reacting
chemical dyes with sustains or even
including in the protein a nucleotide
that has an SH G reactive sy group so in
this case we reacted the K rice protein
with a chemical of reacts with it with
lysines at approximately one molecule of
a duct protein and we matched the asite
of binding by mass spec and we see that
in the inactive form of a left panel
most of the binding is at lysine eighty
eight ninety percent of it and in the
gtp-bound form on the right side and we
see pro venom
reaction of the dye at lycée 128 and a
little bit at IC 104
so after this chemical reaction the
protein is now shg active and we can
then immobilize this on the membrane via
the high frequency red laser beam as the
protein on membranes and then see a
second harmonic wave which can be then
measured and then we can look for
perturbations of the wave as a
measurement of protein binding a small
molecule binding through so it's part of
a development process that we'd like to
have a positive control and one example
is a chemical called metazine which is a
nonspecific chemical which reacts with
many different proteins and protein
kinases in a none specific way but at
least gives us a positive signal to set
up the assay developments as you say
that when we started with experiments
the world of positive controls of
compounds that bind to Rast at high
affinity or even moderate affinity to
use as positive controls so we used the
mezzanine as a meze known as the
positive control and you can see on the
left panel we see in a dose-dependent
manner when we add increasing amounts of
members into the immobilized wrasse we
see a change in the sh t signal now the
sh t signal can either be negative or
positive depending on whether or not the
change in the protein moves the protein
away from the z axis or towards the z
axis so we can see conformational
changes in both directions in this case
the metazine cause a negative sh t
signal and the middle panel shows that
we see is at the same kind of thing on
whether the proteins bound to gdp or to
GTP and these are the kind of results we
see so each of these plots here is a
dose-dependent increase in concentration
of a small molecule the causes and sh t
change in the protein when it were in
rats protein when it interacts you can
see that almost all the compounds that
interact with rass cause the same type
of allosteric change in the same
direction with a few exceptions we stand
out
some go in the opposite direction as you
can see from the panel which is six
boxes from a left on down one slide you
can see that the here the compound
nicely causes a change in orientation
and protein in the opposite direction
and you can see in the bottom panel also
some examples of complemental changes
which are a mule as a direction so these
are very nice dose dependent responses
showing allosteric changes in wrasse on
compound binding and again you can see
different times for binding depending on
the different compound and these are
just more examples of relatively high
affinity binding which show again nice
dose dependent response curves and
mostly in one direction but some also in
the other direction is showing some
selectivity now we've replicated these
these finding events from the whole
library of thousands of compounds done
at different concentrations and you can
see from the replication of these these
analyses that we see a very good
r-squared value as shown in the essay
itself is very reproducible and the data
of very high quality so these assays can
be run on the Delta machine that biota
see as manufacturers in high-throughput
format so we can run literally thousands
of compounds and in a few hours and go
through libraries of kamekona's looking
for the most effective binders and then
we can follow up with these compounds
again the dose response curves I'm
looking for the effects of these
compounds at different concentrations
which he received compounds are bind to
the Rast protein in the active GTP bound
configuration are two different
concentrations or in the gdp
configuration on the right side and this
distribution shows us where most the
compounds fall with respect to the
standard deviation around the center of
the plot on each of the graphs here
so the next step is to really validate
the directed direction the compounds
with the with grass proteins using
either SPR on a surface plasmon
resonance or by mass spec or other
biophysical methods that independently
interact a measure of the finding and
these we've done in this case said at
the group would by the group at
frederick maryland on under the
supervision of andy stephen again we
show that the the very high affinity
binders or the higher affinity binders
from the screen are very we can select
those from the dose response curve that
reproducible and this has moved forward
for further characterization so this
shows the next steps in the process
essentially this isn't an NMR spectrum
which was he performed at the university
of maryland and this shows that in the
presence of the compound we see shifts
on the the NMR spectrum this case the
modest but still reproducible and there
does depend on the shown on the
right-hand panel so although this is a
much more laborious and complicated
technique we can't verify that these
compounds do indeed bind dark odorous
and get an indication of where they
whereabouts they bind based on the ships
on the NMR spectrum on the lower panel
you can see the the plots that we
obtained using the SPR analysis the
surface plasmon resonance another
biophysical method for determining the
direct interaction of a small molecule
with a protein and you can see these are
dose dependent SPR plots they don't look
very pretty because the binding
constants are these compounds are still
Rolo in the 100 micro molar plus range
but this makes the point that these
these fragments although they bind very
cleanly as shown by the NMR spectrum and
with some selectivity the binding is not
sufficiently strong to make them easily
detectable using conventional
biophysical methods such as SPR so we
think that the shg approach is actually
much more sensitive and enabled us to a
much higher throughput
analysis
again these are more more examples of
spectra bind to from the NMR spectrum on
top left and in this particular case the
compound shows differential binding
between the GTP form and the gdp form of
the Rice Protein this is a desirable
feature and again you can see from the
SPR plots at the bottom that we can see
clear evidence of binding but these have
been very not these are not very strong
spr signals that would have been
difficult to detect as primary screens
furthermore we've analyzed other tool
compounds that bind to razz proteins
with low affinity and typically with SPR
we have a problem that if a compound
binds on more than one site the SPR
signals never become saturated and
therefore you don't measure a binding
constant and you can't feel assured the
compound is actually binding selectively
whereas with the sh t method we do see
saturation of conformational changes by
compounds binding locally to the protein
I wish we believed more likely
corresponds to local changes in the rice
protein structure which the SGH sorry
the sh t signal reflects so very nicely
as do the NMR spectra so we think this
is a better technique than SPR for sure
and also much more practical and
convenient than using fragment based NMR
as a primary screen now this shows based
on the NMR spectra at the pocket to
which we think these small fragments
bind based on these shifts we see in the
in the NMR spectrum and you can see the
binder very nicely to a pocket which is
close to a pocket previously identified
by steve Vesak and colleagues and by the
coop at Genentech as a pocket serve
which is suitable for a small molecule
interaction at least with a low affinity
in a sort of shallow shallow group so
that's to summarize we think shg is a
novel and useful way of screening for
compounds to bind to proteins of
interest these screens can be done at
high throughput with small amounts of
target protein
the protein only has to be immobilized
on a surface which can be achieved using
a simple epitope tag we also now know
the protein complexes can be assembled
on these on these membranes and and we
can detect signals from sh t even on
relatively large and complicated protein
complexes because really what we're
looking at is the change in orientation
between a single dye covalently attached
to one of the proteins and the membrane
to which the protein is attached that's
the basis of sh t so it's so it's a very
robust and simple technique following
hits from these screens then it's
necessary to go to the next step which
is some typically independent
biophysical analysis using SPR or
possible NMR hopefully x-ray
crystallography biochemical screens and
typically the next step involves
medicinal chemistry to improve the
initial hits to make them new into high
affinity compounds which could be the
beginning of the whole process of
developing bioactive compounds so with
that I will like to wrap up and gave
knowledge the work of Elizabeth Donahue
wrote in my lab that did the most of the
work here in collaboration with
colleagues Chelsey Lasky and friends at
cell biology thank you very much
thank you dr. McCormick from that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019 as
a final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
email that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
next time
goodbye